[Musique]
les audiences sont incroyables vous
faites des pics à 4,1 millions de
téléspectateurs alors que sur france 2
il ya un million de téléspectateurs à la
même heure est ce que pour vous déjà
c'est c'est une victoire ou est ce que
c'est une fierté parce que c'est vrai
que sous
gennak à un oui bah oui normalement les
black eyed peas devaient venir dans
l'après-midi faire les répétitions puis
ils avaient ils ont un concert ce soir
et puis après ils avaient dit non mais
on revient pour faire le direct sauf que
comme l'a dit pascal le côté ils sont là
dans cinq minutes ça a duré deux heures
et puis le périphérique est un peu
compliquée voilà c'est ça et puis
ensuite quand ils sont arrivés dans les
loges c'est ok il s'habille ils sont là
dans cinq minutes la ce a duré une heure
nous sommes tous ici pour donner de
l'amour et pour rendre hommage et
supporter les personnes autour de nous
qui ont des soucis nous sommes tous
global cityzens
une petite envie même avant monte sur
cette énergie
coutu c'est à la fin là c'est sûr que
quand on sort d'une loge avec eux de
quoi se soulager c'est vrai arrivée sur
un plateau dix ans que je peux aller aux
toilettes avait juste envie dire mais ça
fait deux heures que tu es à côté bon
peu importe toujours est il que les
visions est intéressant j'ai pris hier
soir non ils ont moi j'ai pu pour rien
ils ont pris une belle tôle
non mais alors que non mais attends hier
soir vous avez regardé ce que vous
regardez moi j'ai eu le temps de
regarder j'ai juste vu des images alors
le décor on dira un crématorium et j'ai
vu tu t'étais foot n'ont jamais mais que
les autres parce que franchement
l'épilation d'après les
tcc je te jure c'est un peu ce que tu
pourrais jamais non c'est un bourreau
qui
d'épilation d'après l'été fait un bon
gros kiff
lévis
[Musique]
sur les cuisses
quand on regarde les photos de vous sur
instagram êtes souvent torse nu et alors
on apprend dans votre livre que vous
faites beaucoup de sport toujours
hydrater votre peau et vos mains
plusieurs fois par jour avec deux trois
douches quotidiennes vous traquer jusque
vos poils du nez c'est qu'elle est
racontée par je n'ai pas que pas que si
vous avez toute la vérité dimanche matin
je me fais filer le dos les facteurs
d'abord
exprimé mes regrets ça posait plus vite
parfois avec une triple repousse
et la honte à chaud je te jure tu sors
de là mais
tu les verras plus les poches des
banquiers
fait quelques bros
[Rires]
je vous prie de m'excuser je vous
présente mes plus plates excuses eric
dupond moretti non non les spectacles
bien mais parie que tu un balai dans le
cul moi je la connais je la connais de
nulle part c'est la preuve que la
rencontre est vrai que je dis ça parce
qu'on m'a dit pour le détendre mois
non seulement le mot 10h03 après je le
vois lui me dit pareil quoi
moi j'ai fourni le ballet
ok ça va très lourd à la batterie
sur ma fiche et à votre âge jean-marc à
non non non non non faut pas y penser
sinon vivre
alors sachez que c'est déjà apparu à
l'écran lorsque j'avais 10 ans qui est
l'âge où les données alors
quarante deux 42 rue c'est plus c'est
plus mon nom ça on peut pas dire non non
mais sérieusement n'ont pas cessé déjà
parus à l'ambiance voulue ok d'accord on
peut pas leur sachet alors on le retire
pas on le retire on est en direct
37 ce téléthon
vous êtes passés de 15000 euros par mois
à laval à près d'un million après 98 le
qatar du temps vous y êtes parti pour
les millions
c'est honnête sincèrement c'est juste
face se foutent de la gueule que de dire
je pars au qatar pour le projet football
yahia n'a jamais il ne jouera jamais
être qu'admiratif s'élève à un million
de 1907 en
1907 il a fait
[Musique]
je ne dirai qu'un seul mot
j'échoue est lourd à ma vie d'amour la
plus belle année sociale la plus belle
ma nouvelle pub yes we le sens de la
vérité a mérité sa foulée péri mais elle
mérite et c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup
ce que nous venons vous le savez mon
regard se pose sur elle quotidiennement
trahi mes sentiments et jetant les
parents non c'est ainsi qu'à répondre
quoi rien simplement vous taire car
c'est souvent les silences que les
femmes sont les plus belles
marcal même
[Musique]
chic et voir le cas moi il y avait la
nana que j'ai connu il ya deux ans à
l'été en string et les strings de là bas
c'est d'esprit c'est la mer a dit
stream5 une gomme très fin et les fins
sont des des incidents de parcours si tu
en reçois c'est donc des filles qui à 21
ans n'ont plus rien et elle sont
fascinants
[Musique]
je suis très concentré ce mage latine et
là je n'ai pas le temps de réfléchir
oula
c'est rien non j'ai rien vu venir ça a
été du chaplin la mort
[Musique]
ça peut paraître improbable mais il ya
des gens qui choisissent de diffuser les
sardines à fond en plein enterrement en
fait aux moyens image une foraine qui
avait 91 ans quitte une femme six ans
formidable qui m'a doré et qui a demandé
à avoir ça et j'ai eu son fils au
téléphone après qui m'a dit mais ça a
mis un peu de gaieté dans son départ
dans tout ça